who's going to vote on thursday
and who is voting for the first time
there is no one here who's aged
35 or older in this popular food kiosk
on the outskirts of kampala
politics dominates the conversation
however some including richard chigeni
don't have a voters card
i want to vote but i could not register
i lost my id card
and the process of getting another one
is long
james cassiband on the other hand says
nothing
will stop him from casting his ballot in
the past as part of our upbringing
we thought it was up to the elders to
decide on the country's affairs
but looking at the social and economic
challenges we are facing i think it's
time to stand up and claim our rightful
position in politics
two-thirds of registered voters are
below the age of 30
which means they have only ever seen
76-year-old president johari museveni in
power
museveni started a social media campaign
recently
to try and gain young people support he
exercises
takes part in popular dance challenges
among other things
uganda has the second largest young
population
on the continent of tunisia most here
tell us they are
marginalized they say they have no jobs
and feel disconnected from their
country's leadership but in previous
elections many have been reluctant
to engage in politics or even vote
38 year old bobby wein pop star turned
politician
and the president's strongest challenger
is banking on the voters of his
generation to bark him
there has been in the past years
a very big divide a very big gap between
young people
and the way they are governed however
for the last three years we have been
sensitizing
people connecting them to the politics
of their country
president museveni supporters say he
still has a huge support base
especially in rural areas president
seven has a vision
it's a vision he shared with ugandans it
is about a transformation for this
country
and for as long as ugandans believe he's
the right person to steer this country
in that direction i'm sure they're going
to give him that mandate
back at the food kiosk they say they
want change they want jobs
lower taxes and money in their pockets
catherine soy al jazeera
kampala